so i'm sitting here searching my name
uh through uh you know twitter search
like i always do
and um i find this uh post by ryan
miller
and it asks a great question um have i
sold out
and it's a great it's a great piece uh
he really isn't being mean in
any way he actually says that you know
part of my brand equity and his opinion
is that
um i'm very accessible to my community
answer my emails as he goes into saying
i know you guys can't see this um as he
goes into saying
somewhere in here but here's where it
gets complicated i'd argue that his fans
are so passionate because in addition to
putting out great content he's
accessible
he interacts with his tribe on a regular
basis he answers emails
every email it appears to be true i've
received many responses from his uh
inquiries blah blah blah and it goes out
to saying that you know
it's about like a band getting bigger
and then you don't know
i guess i'm doing this video because
once and for all i want to squash
the conversation there is no thing as
selling out or fame changing anybody or
money or more eyeballs on them here's
what it is guys it's very simple
more eyeballs more tension it just
accentuates it doesn't accentuate
it just exposes who you are it exposes
who you are so ryan
and anybody else wondering yes i'm
stretching my brand i'm doing obsessed
i'm doing different things some uh
what's uh had a great comment here
uh from rachel her fir she was the first
person she says
what uh with when your primary business
is selling wine the wine library tv.com
is
an ex a logical brand expect extension
excuse me corked as a logical
brand extension uh an interview show
around celeb obsessed ladies is not
quite the progression for gary
vaynerchuk so i think he risk
runs the risk of not much selling out
but extending his brand far
outside his core competency also very
cool but you know i've got to scratch my
own itch i want to do lots of things but
what i want to stay really focused on is
this point
it's you know what more money more
problems more attention
only does one thing it only shows
everybody who you are
i promise you if the whole world cares
about what i have to say
all they're gonna find out is that my
mom and dad did a phenomenal job
see what happens is the world just gets
to know you that much better because
there's that many eyeballs at you
so i challenge and promise the world
to catch me on videotape kicking a child
or slamming a door on an old lady
it's not going to happen you are who you
are and
your dna defines you and your upbringing
defines you
and the more eyeballs on you is just an
opportunity to show how true and real
you are so ryan
great point i agree but i promise you
the people that become
famous or infamous or what have you they
just get exposed
so the ones that are awesome to begin
with end up being awesome to a lot more
people
and the ones that were jerk-offs just
end up being jerk-offs
so that's just the way it rolls